when I wrote the books i did on AI came
out 25 years ago it was a very very
different time in the in the discipline
and you know I wrote a book about a
group of grad students at Berkeley who
were trying to program a computer to
have common sense in particular that was
you know there was one guy who was you
know who had given his computer a
problem which was that the computer you
know was where anthropomorphize in here
a bit but the computer woke up in the
morning and it looked outside and it saw
that it was raining and had to decide to
put on a ring cut before it went outside
so really the whole book and away was
about this guy trying to get his
computer to put on a raincoat and you
know with with without great success and
one of the things that interested me
about Berkeley was not only was this you
know sort of compelling a group of
students and and a faculty advisor who
had worked with Roger shank at Yale do
one of the leading AI researchers but
they're also a couple of philosophers
there who for different reasons took
issue with the whole idea of a I one of
them was you know Henry Dreyfuss who
argued that this approach wasn't going
to work that it was sort of like I think
the metaphor that he used was you know
like building a stairway to the moon yes
it would get you closer but it wouldn't
get you there and that's kind of what's
happened this idea that you can you know
program a computer to you know have to
be in situations and to have you know
certain types of thoughts that you you
know give it in some you know more or
less godlike way has really you know not
Panda and what is happening is that you
know we're beginning to see emergence
systems you know systems where you know
computers are you know begin to show
emergent intelligence and that seems to
you know in that work in a way that
somewhat resembles the brain in that
they're you know massively parallel
processing and you know that sort of
thing so you know that seems to be a
much more you know much more promising
area and you know I think I think now
you know people like Kurzweil are
forecasting some some pretty radical
developments you know we'll we'll see
where that goes but it's certainly it's
certainly a long way from where it was
when I was writing